عدم إنشاء هذا الفيديو
لأنك تعرف أنه من المحتمل أن
يكون وقتًا عاطفيًا لأنني
أشعر بسخط وازدراء متزايدين بسبب
عدم كفاءتي المتصورة على مستوى السياسة
الخارجية وأريد أن أطرح بعض
الأسئلة على وجه التحديد لبعض كبار قادتي
[الموسيقى
]  الاسم هو
[موسيقى]
الناس مستاءون لأن كبار
قادتهم خذلوهم ولم
يرفع أي منهم أيديهم ويقبل
المساءلة أو يقول إننا أفسدنا الأمر
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] وأنا لا أقول أنه يتعين علينا
في أفغانستان إلى الأبد ، لكني أقول
إن أيًا منكم ألقى رتبتك على
الطاولة وأقول إنها فكرة سيئة أن يتم
إخلاء مطار باغرام من
الحواجز الجوية الاستراتيجية قبل إخلاء الجميع
وما سأقوله
هو من موقعي
المحتمل  كل هؤلاء الناس ماتوا
بلا جدوى إذا لم يكن لدينا كبار القادة
الذين
يمتلكون أيديهم ويرفعون أيديهم ويقولون
إننا لم نفعل ذلك جيدًا في النهاية
دون أن نستمر في تكرار
نفس الخطأ
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
]  أنت